‏m
‏se
ا
[Silence]
خ
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
السلام ورحمه
وه الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد
ولا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول الله
حي على
الصلاه حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على
الفلاح حي على
الفلاح الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا لا اله الا
الله ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستهديه ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات اعمالنا من يهدي الله فهو المهتد
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه والتابعين اما بعد
معاشر الموحدين عباد الله فان اصدق الكلام
كلام الله عز وجل وان خير الهدي هدي محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم وان شر الامور
محدثاتها وان كل محدثه بدعه وان كل بدعه
ضلاله وان كل ضلاله في النار اسال الله
العظيم رب العرش العظيم بمنه وكرمه وعفوه
ان يجيرني واياكم منها انه ولي ذلك
والقادر عليه اما بعد فيقول الله سبحانه
وتعالى يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي
خلقكم من نفس
واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث منهما رجالا
كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي
تساءلون به والارحام ان الله كان عليكم
رقيبا ويقول سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين
امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا تموتن الا
وانتم
مسلمون ويقول سبحانه يا ايها الذين امنوا
اتقوا الله وقولوا قولا سديدا يصلح لكم
اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما
بعد الكلام هو هبه من الله سبحانه وتعالى
وفضل من الرحمن اعطاه الله
الانسان ليفصح عما بداخله من المشاعر
والاحاسيس
فسبحانه وتعالى يقول الرحمن علم القران
خلق الانسان علمه
البيان فلا بد ان يكون معلوما لدى المسلم
ان الكلام من من عمل الانسان الذي سوف
يحاسب عليه فان كان خيرا فخير وان كان شرا
فشر وكما يقال ان كان
الصمت يحمد في حال فان الكلام يحمد في
احوال كثيره وقد جعل الله سبحانه
وتعالى اطايب الكلام في خير المقام بل جعل
كلمه التوحيد والتي بها الدنيا والاخره من
طيب
الكلام فقال سبحانه
وتعالى الم تر كيف ضرب الله مثلا كلمه
طيبه كشجره طيبه اصلها ثابت وفرعها في
السماء
‏spe الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى inside us from feelings and expr
feelings and
ide الله سبحانه وتالى
‏tr
se سبحانه وتالى
الرحمن علم القران خلق الانسان علمه
البيان spe
[Silence]
‏and of times say
spe
isis in one
sit spe
[Silence]
اله الا
الله والكلام انواع واقسام ولا بد ان يكون
معلوما لد معاشر
المسلمين ان الله طيب لا لا يقبل الا طيبا
وهو سبحانه وتعالى الذي جال مداد الايمان
الكلمه
الطيبه تسقي شجره
في قلب المؤمن فهنالك تلازم عجيب بين
الكلمه الطيبه والعمل الصالح يقول سبحانه
وتعالى اليه يصعد الكلم الطيب والعمل
الصالح
يرفعه يقال في التفاسير يرفع العمل الصالح
الكلم الطيب وقيل ان الكلم الطيب يرفع
العمل
الصالح فهذا تلازم بين قبول ال والكلام
الطيب فقد يعمل المر ولا يجد لهذا العمل
قبولا عند الله لخبث منطقه وسو
كلامه سبحانه
وتعالى ان الله طيب لا لا يقبل الا طيب
[Silence]
تبح
استغفار ذكر
[Silence]
طيبه the point make
سبحانه
[Silence]
وتالى اليه يصعد الكلم الطيب والعمل
‏words
spe spe
[Silence]
لذلك كان الهي النبوي
الشريف عن القز والسب والشت واللعن والطعن
لانها كلها من الماحيات الساحقات للاعمال
والفضائل وقد ثبت في الحديث ان الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم قال ليس المؤمن ليس المؤمن
بالطعان ولاع ولا الفاحش
البذ ويقول الله سبحانه وتعالى اتقوا الله
وقولوا قولا
سديدا
الله سنه قران
‏prop صلى الله عليه
وسلم
حث الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
ف الكلمه الطيبه هي هويه المسلم وبطاقته
التعريفيه وهي عماد الدعوه الى الله وهي
وسيله لقبول الخير والشر وهي وسيله لدخول
القلوب وهي وسيله للتعبير عن اصدق المشاعر
وهي وسيله لمعالجه الالم وهي وسيله
للتخفيف والتلطف
والاحسان للناس ولذلك يقول الله سبحانه
وتعالى وقولوا للناس
حسنا وقولوا للناس حسنى وقل لعبادي يقول
التي هي احسن فهذا نبينا صلى الله عليه
وسلم على اعلى درجات الصدق والاخلاق
والاخلاص في
الدعوه الى ان الى ان التوجيه الرباني كان
له فبما رحمه من الله
لهم ولو كنت فضا غليظ القلب لانفضوا من
[Silence]
حولك الله عليه
وسلم اتقوا الله وقولوا قلا سديدا الله
‏id
[Silence]
‏to
‏people
people to ex those kind
feeling to
thees people
قران الله سبحانه
وتالى اسرا
is وقولوا للناس
حسنا الله سبحانه
وتالى وقولوا لناس
حسن الله عليه وسلم الله سبحان وتالى
say
my say وقبا يقول التي هي
احسن صل الله عليه
وسم
mercy الله سبحانه وتالى
صل الله عليه
وسم
justification الله سبحانه وتالى
justification الله سبحانه
وتالى لن فضوا من
حولك
would
softness if
الناس اليوم في زحام او في زحام من الالام
والهموم والضغوط العمليه والنفسيه فربما
تكون انت اليوم من تملك المفتاح لسعادتهم
وسرورهم بكلمه طيبه او كما يقال لا يوجد
اسحر من الكلمه
الطيبه لا يوجد اسحر من الكلمه الطيبه
اللينه وتاثيرها على على قلبي وسمعي
المتلقي مهما بلغ الانسان من
الطغيان مهما بلغ الانسان من الطغيان فان
الكالم لها سحرها البلاغ في تحويل البغضاء
الى محبه والكفر الى
ايمان ففرعون طاغيه التاريخ
لما ارسل الله سبحانه وتعالى موسى
كريمه فكان التوجيه الرباني لموسى فقولا
له قولا لينا لعله يتذكر او
يخشى فرعون يا
رب الذي قتل واستباح وطغى في البلاد يقول
الله فقونا له قولا لينا لعله يتذكر او
يخشى
فما بالك باخيك المسلم هو اولى من
فرعون وهو اولى بالكلمه
الطيبه منك
[Silence]
‏a spe and
‏mind the
imp good word can in someone heart and
people has
magic as say there no magic great a
good and
impact not only not only directed to say
people
الله سبحانه وتعالى
مو الله مو وق
ل يا اللهون
[Silence]
الله قلب المؤمن لابد ان يكون ينبط بروائع
الكلم الطيب صدقا وحبا واخلاصا
لله ولذلك ربط الايمان بالكلمه الطيبه ربط
الايمان بخير الكلام في قوله صلى الله
عليه وسلم عن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه من
كان يؤمن بالله واليوم الاخر فليقل خيرا
او
ليصمت
حديث صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏let you have the option to say good but
if you have good to say
atent do not cuse more dam
[Silence]
من كان يؤمن بالله واليوم
الاخر الكلمه لم
تجد لها عندك متسعا من الخير فحبسها هو
الخير
كله يقول الله يقول سبحانه وت يقول الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم عن ابي هريره رضي الله
عنه في الحديث ان العبد لا يتكلم بالكلمه
من رضوان الله لا يقي لها بالا يرفعه الله
بها درجات وان العبد ليتكلم بالكلمه من
سخط الله لا يوقي لها بالا يهوي بها في
جهنم صلى الله عليه
وسلم حث ابي هريره ابو هريره
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
اذ بال
عود لسانك قول الخير تحظى به ان اللسان
لما عودت يعتاد بارك الله لي ولكم بالقران
العظيم ونفعني واياكم بما فيه من الايات
والذكر الحكيم اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر
الله لي ولكم فاستغفروه انه الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على المبعوث رحمه للعالمين اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
والتابعين لما سال معاذ النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم قال يا رسول الله اخبرني بعمل
يدخلني الجنه ويباعدني من النار قال لقد
سالت عن عظيم وانه ليسير على من يسره الله
له على من يسره الله عليه ثم بعد ان عد له
ابواب الخير كلها قال الا اخبرك بملاك ذلك
كله قلت بلى يا رسول الله قال كف عليك هذا
واشار الى
لسانه قلت يا نبي الله وانا
لمؤاخذون بما نتكلم
به فقال كلتك امك يا معاذ وهل يكب الناس
في النار على
وجوههم الا
حصنتهم معاذ بن جبل رضي الله
عنه صلى الله عليه
وسلمن ‏between between me and h
fire he said you ask about a matter with
great it's easy but not
everybody it's easy for the
one makes it
easy matter is
easy that
to
said easy
‏prop صل الله عليه
وسمير of
goodness he said do you know what all
this then heed his and he said control
this he said this that
صل الله عليه
وسلم said
[Silence]
اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في الاولين
وصل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في الاخرين وصل
وسلم على سيدنا محمد في كل وقت وحين اللهم
صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد حتى ترث الارض ومن
عليها وانت خير الوارثين اللهم اعز
الاسلام والمسلمين الله اللهم اعز الاسلام
والمسلمين واعلي كلمتي الحق والدين المبين
وانصر اخواننا المستضافين في كل مكان
اللهم انصر اخواننا المسلمين المستضعفين
في كل مكان في غزه والسودان اللهم اصلح
احوالنا واحوالهم وانت سميع الدعاء اللهم
اصلح احوالنا واحوالهم وانت سميع الدعاء
اللهم سهم احفظهم بما تحفظ به اوليائك
اللهم تقبل شهدائهم اللهم تقبل شهدائهم
وارحم موتاهم واقل عشرتهم اللهم نفس كربهم
اللهم نفس كربهم وفرج همهم وكن لهم معينا
وانت خير الناصرين اللهم ككل لهم معينا
وانت خير
الناصرين اللهم تجاوز عنا السيئات وتحمل
عنا التبعات اللهم انز والدينا عنا خير
الجزاء اللهم اجزي سيدنا محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم عنا خير ما جزيت به نبيا عن
امته اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه والتابعين اللهم احينا على سنه
نبينا محمد اللهم احينا على سنته وامتنا
على ملته واوردنا حوضه واكتب لنا شفاعته
يا رب
العالمين عباد الله ان الله يامر بالعدل
والاحسان وايتاء ذ القربى وينهى عن
الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعدكم لعلكم
تذكرون واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب
العالمين واقم الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله حي على الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد
قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا لا اله الا
الله استقيم اعتدلوا س الصفد
الخلل الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعم
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين تبارك الذي جعل في
السماء
بروجا وجعل
فيها وجعل فيها
سراجا وقمرا
منيرا وهو الذي جعل الليل
والنهار خلفه لمن
اراد لمن اراد
ان يذكر او اراد
شكورا وعباد الرحمن الذين يمشون على الارض
هونا واذا خطبهم
الجاهلون قالوا
سلاما والذين يبيتون لربهم
سجدا
وقياما والذين يقولون ربنا اصرف عنا عذاب
جهنم ان عذابها كان
غراما انها ساءت
مستقرا
ومقاما الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
والذين اذا انفقوا لم يسرفوا ولم
يقتروا وكان بين ذلك
قواما والذين لا يدعون مع الله الها اخر
ولا
يقتلون ولا يقتلون النفس التي حرم الله
الا بالحق ولا
يزنون
ومن يفعل ذلك يلقى
اثاما يضاعف له العذاب يوم
القيامه ويخلد فيه
مهانا الا من تاب وامن وعمل عملا صالحا
فاولئك
ف
اولئك يبدل الله
سيئاتهم
حسنات وكان الله غفورا
رحيما الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر
س
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
الله السلام
[Silence]
‏and
لام
[Silence]
الن بسم الله
‏po
[Silence]
ان